la première mission du président de la
République c'est de protéger les
Français il a parlé cet après-midi il a
dit quelque chose d'extrêmement
important à savoir qu'il faut arrêter
avec cette panique généralisée on est
dans une forme d'hystérie collective à
se poser des questions sur que va
devenir l'ascenseur que vont devenir les
feux de circulation alors qu'en réalité
l'objectif c'est de passer l'hiver on
pourra rentrer dans le détail il y a une
situation qui est complexe qui est
tendue va falloir faire des efforts les
entreprises en font on a déjà baissé de
6-7% à la consommation c'est très
important faut continuer à en faire mais
ça sert à rien de prévoir le scénario du
pire en permanence et de crier avant
d'avoir mal et c'est ce qu'a dit le
président a arrêté de crier avant
d'avoir mal l'objectif c'est qu'on
mobilise tout le monde et c'est comme ça
qu'on arrivera à passer l'hiver faut
vraiment arrêter de faire peur aux gens
arrêtez de faire peur aux gens
il est dans une hystérie capillaire lui
respectueusement mode vous me faites
peur vous dites
l'objectif c'est de passer l'hiver vous
rendez compte c'est-à-dire que moi trois
fois en boîte moi tu lui fais peur
moi j'ai peur on passe pas l'hiver oui
et vous avez enedis qui nous dit c'est
panic à bord le président qui nous
rassure en fait on nous ment j'ai
l'impression que personne au
gouvernement ne sait rien qui te manque
tout le monde le gouvernement ne sait
pas en fait moi j'ai l'impression que
c'est de l'improvisation
c'est quoi ta question mon chéri
êtes-vous une menteuse
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je suis pas venu là pour répondre à ce
genre de question vous m'en voudrez pas
non pour expliquer un peu ce qui se
passe sur un système électrique il faut
que à tout moment on produise autant que
ce qu'on consomme et on a des en ce
moment on va vivre en hiver qui est pas
simple pour plusieurs raisons d'une part
il y a la guerre en Ukraine tous les
personnes
je termine ce qui a ce qui implique que
on a moins d'approvisionnement en gaz
qu'avant on a des problèmes sur le
parking clair les centrales fonctionnent
moins bien que ce qu'elles font ce
qu'elles les hivers dernier et donc
c'est un peu plus tendu c'est pour ça
qu'on a demandé aux entreprises aux
administrations de faire des efforts
maintenant on maîtrise pas tout c'est un
petit peu si je peux faire un parallèle
qui est un petit peu limite mais comme
dans la crise du coronavirus ça veut
dire que il y a un certain nombre de
données qu'on maîtrise qu'on connaît et
puis on a par exemple certaines
incertitudes est-ce que vous vous savez
quelle météo il va faire en janvier
alors si vous savez je suis preneuse la
seule chose
comme ça sur lequel on est pas sûr et
donc on est tout en oeuvre pour que même
dans le cas le plus difficile on arrive
à passer l'hiver et que les Français
soient pas impactés moi je comprends que
les Français ils puissent être inquiets
je comprends que tu sais être en colère
je comprends que vous puissiez être en
colère mais je viens là pour vous
répondre pour vous dire ce qu'on sait et
pourquoi est-ce que ma conviction c'est
que les Français se mobilisent et que ça
va bien se passer alors c'est quoi les
Français mobiles ils doivent faire quoi
alors les Français c'est d'abord les
entreprises et les administrations parce
qu'en fait c'est elle qui consomment le
plus et puis c'est normal de demander au
gros de faire d'abord des efforts
je le fais voilà je conseille pas à tous
les Français qui nous écoutent d'arrêter
d'aller au bureau comme Cyril mais en
tout état de cause que je veux dire
c'est que l'exemplarité doit venir du
haut et c'est pour ça que c'est d'abord
les grandes entreprises
les grandes entreprises les grandes
administrations l'État qui a mis en
place des plantes sobriété est-ce que
par exemple à l'Élysée ils allument les
lumières et ensuite les lumières le
chauffage on fait attention je peux vous
dire qu'à l'Assemblée nationale par
exemple
on n'a pas toujours chaud le lien
autrement et donc mais c'est normal faut
montrer l'exemple et puis une fois qu'on
aura demandé à tous ces grandes
entreprises administration de faire des
efforts si besoin pour demander aux
Français
des gens très intelligents qui gèrent
tout ça c'est que sans contradiction
pour un hiver moyen il y a entre 0 et 5
jours où on pourrait avoir des tensions
ça veut dire que entre 0 et 5 jours il
faudra qu'on fasse un peut-être un peu
plus attention mais enfin la France va
pas s'arrêter de vivre la Terre va
passer à arrêter de tourner donc encore
une fois sortir de cette dynamique le
matin comme on l'a dit aujourd'hui
pour moi l'éducation c'est absolument
prioritaire Emmanuel Macron pendant le
covid j'étais venu là pour en parler
d'ailleurs ça avait fait objet de
nombreux débats dans ces grandes
priorités c'était on garde les écoles
ouvertes moi ma conviction c'est que le
Président de la République il fera tout
pour que les enfants ne soient pas ceux
qui paient les problèmes qu'on a sur le
réseau alors moi mes enfants il a
toujours fait il l'a toujours fait j'ai
aucun doute il continuera à le faire
alors on va voir justement ce qu'a dit
le président est-ce qu'il a poussé un
coup de gueule tout à l'heure alors la
question que tout le monde se pose c'est
pourquoi le Président nous rassure est
enedis eux ils ont l'air en totale
rassera et même le même gouvernement
ici si je vous dis vous allez être payé
vous avez pas demandé à Bernard Montiel
alors que Emmanuel Macron parfois des
choses qui ne sont pas exactement
vous avez pas de payer
le débat est absurde
étape absurde le rôle des autorités
publiques des entreprises publiques ça
n'est pas de transférer la peur ni de
gouverner par la peur et donc le rôle du
gouvernement des ministres des
opérateurs c'est de faire leur travail
pour fournir de l'énergie
c'est tout et ensuite c'est d'appeler
chacun la responsabilité pour qu'il y
ait de la sobriété c'est pas de
commencer à faire peur aux gens avec des
scénarios absurdes et des choses comme
j'ai entendu ces dernières heures stop à
tout ça nous sommes un grand pays on a
un grand modèle énergétique nous allons
tenir cet hiver malgré la guerre et donc
je demande à chacun de faire son travail
le travail de DF c'est de faire tourner
les centrales le travail du gouvernement
c'est qu'il y a une planification le
travail de tout le monde c'est qu'on
déroule la sobriété les scénarios de la
peur pas pour moi on reste tous unis et
on avant voilà apparemment vous l'avez
vu
tout le temps à ma femme ne dépense pas
plus d'argent que ce que je gagne pour
toi et on va passer l'hiver tu vas voir
c'est pas c'est pas con mais naüm non
mais effectivement si le président
Macron tape du point sur la table c'est
donc bien qu'il y a eu cafouillage c'est
donc bien qu'en terme de à minima de
communication pour les Français c'est
Inaudi parce que à un moment on nous a
dit on va vous prévoir des scénarios
catastrophes au cas où puis après on
rétropédale ce ne sont que des scénarios
au cas où il n'y aura pas puis après
henné 10 nous dit oui mais attention
parce que les feux rouges ou les gens
qui sont pas et donc nous on est
complètement
perdu
les mecs je veux dire un truc après là
c'est comme la crise du covid c'est
normal qu'à un moment tu es face à une
situation que tu connais pas donc
normalement tu te tonnes c'est comme moi
quand j'allais à l'Acropole je savais
pas que le dimanche soir il y avait les
coiffeuses il était plus que les
esthéticaires je voilà je tâtonnais ah
voilà et après j'ai voilà j'ai compris
bah le covid pareil la crise énergétique
ça l'a jamais arrivé donc là forcément
aussi on tape
on peut pas mettre les gens dans cette
situation c'est pas la même personne qui
vous a mis dans cette situation
tous les spécialistes disent qu'il va y
avoir des problèmes cet hiver
monsieur Macron comme pour le covid vous
l'avez tous les deux dit c'est de dire
tout et son contraire comme ça quoi
qu'il arrive il aura il pourra dire
qu'il a eu raison il pourra dire qu'il a
eu raison s'il y a des coupures ah je
vous avais dit il fallait bien prévoir
et s'il y a pas de coupure il dit
le président pourrait dire je vais
donner un million d'euros par jour
critiquer si c'est critiquable je suis
objective
toi voilà tu représentes l'Amérique
franchement
le problème vient de très loin en fait
c'était à l'époque non par rapport au
centrales nucléaires c'est pour ça qu'on
risque de manquer un peu ça vient de
Jospin qui était premier ministre qui a
voulu pactiser avec des écolos pour
gagner des voix sous la présidence de
Hollande et donc là rappelez-vous une
époque les centrales nucléaires finis on
enroulait pas c'était dégueulasse
pour savoir juste des coupures
électricité de 2 heures par jour faire
dire 15 à 17 parce que moi je suis
souvent une plaie entre 15 et 17h
FIFA 2023 est-ce que juriste me
retrouver comme un con si j'ai pas
sauvegardé mon match on a tous les
moyens aujourd'hui pour faire en sorte
que ça arrive pas et que tu puisses
continuer ton match d'accord on va faire
quoi d'accord on a les moyens de faire
en sorte que les gens puissent tous les
soirs continuent à regarder TPMP puisse
continuer à tourner ton émission et pour
ça comment on fait comment on fait
d'abord on a fait le plein de stocks de
gaz
100% 100%, il y a du gaz de fou ensuite
on démarre petit à petit les réacteurs
problème c'est qu'on s'est retrouvé avec
un tiers du parc nucléaire à l'arrêt et
que le nucléaire c'est 60% de notre
électricité donc quand vous en avez un
tir en rade vous comprenez que ça pose
quelques petits problèmes EDF travail
et d'ailleurs moi je salue les
techniciens aujourd'hui je sois les
mécaniciens les robinettiers les
chaudronniers qui travaillent très dur
sur les chantiers en 3,8 pour faire en
sorte que les maintenances soient faites
correctement dans les temps que les
réacteurs donc ils travaillent comme des
redémont voilà exactement il y a
aujourd'hui plein de gens de la filière
donc tous les secteurs de l'énergie qui
bossent pour que on arrive justement à
passer l'univers convenablement ce que
je dis en revanche c'est que il est
possible qu'il y a des moments de
tension et pendant les moments de
tension on va demander ce que je disais
avant aux entreprises aux
administrations et en dernier lieu aux
Français de faire des efforts est-ce que
les Français c'est on pourrait les vides
on pourra l'éviter ou pas mais les
Français on pourra les visiter c'est
pour ça qu'on demande d'abord on va
demander le max aux entreprises et aux
administrations et notamment aux grosses
entreprises celles qui consomment
beaucoup
de réduire leur consommation pour qu'on
n'est pas à demander des efforts aux
Français on a demandé beaucoup d'efforts
aux Français ces dernières années sur le
covid
et donc vraiment l'idée c'est de
préserver autant que possible et de
protéger les gens très bien parce que
janvier là après Noël déjà tu as plus
d'oseille en janvier tu es comme un con
il fait des périodes
froid c'est février
puis après
le matin il fait nuit tu te tu te lèves
le soir il fait nuit
une dernière chose qui est importante
c'est
qu'en plus faut demander aux Français de
faire des efforts mais aujourd'hui le
prix de l'énergie il est toute façon
cher et les gens ils font déjà des
efforts au quotidien c'est aussi pour ça
que je dis que c'est aux entreprises et
aux administrations de prendre leur part
attention on va demander au mérite parce
que j'ai vu qu'il y avait des déco de
Noël tout ça là parce que j'ai entendu
parler est-ce qu'on passe pour lui
demander pardon par un Hidalgo d'arrêter
le marteau-piqueur
alors
en tout cas il y a beaucoup de maires
aujourd'hui qui de façon proactive
volontairement ou proposer des plantes
sobriété pour faire attention dans leur
ville alors ça veut pas dire qu'on coupe
tout parce que avec décoration de Noël
ça fait aussi plaisir aux enfants ça
consomme pas forcément énormément pour
certaines par contre je pense que ça
suffira pas pour demander à nidalgo
d'arrêter les travaux
qui voulez-vous sucer oui
ça commence bien donc qu'est-ce que vous
pensez de l'idée de la suggestion de
Sandrine Rousseau qui dit couper la
capacité dans les aéroports et les
supermarchés
dans le noir
le concours Lépine de la sobriété donc
là on a les aéroports
de l'électricité qu'on produit
aujourd'hui les écologistes et la France
insoumise ils passent leur temps à nous
dire il faut arrêter de nucléaire et
quand le nucléaire fonctionne pas
suffisamment bien et donc on a des
problèmes sur l'approvisionnement il
râle parce que le nucléaire fonctionne
pas suffisamment bien et ensuite il
demande qu'on arrête les décorations de
Noël et les aéroports voilà il faut être
un peu cohérent un peu de rationalité
tout ça devrait bien se passer il faut
l'aborder le calme et
arrêtez c'est de surenchère
une application alors en France RTE quel
réseau de transport d'électricité eux
ils sont responsables de faire en sorte
qu'on ait bien toujours reproduction
égale consommation à tout moment puisque
l'électricité ça se stocke pas donc on
est obligé d'avoir l'équilibre en
permanence Ecowatt c'est une application
que vous pouvez télécharger sur votre
téléphone et qu'on voit ici et qui va
vous dire est-ce que on est dans un
moment de tension ou pas et ça permettra
par exemple si un mardi on est sur un
moment où c'est particulièrement
difficile mais la veille vous aurez une
petite notification en disant voilà
demain éventuellement
d'alerter des entreprises d'alerter les
services publics et c'est extrêmement
bien fait et d'ailleurs il y a on a
dépassé hier le million de
téléchargements des couettes ça a doublé
en l'espace de quelques jours ce qui est
bien la preuve que les Français ils sont
responsables
bien sûr la biographie
est-ce que vous pouvez rassurer les
Français tu as l'électricité statique
les gens qui sont sous respiratoires
artificiel dont on a dit qu'il n'était
pas prioritaire les gens les gens dans
le premier vital peut être engagé
est une aberration et moi je comprends
d'une part que ça met très en colère les
gens et que c'est excellent et que ça
les inquiète pour
leur quotidien
des personnes prioritaires et ce sera
des personnes prioritairement qu'on
cherchera à protéger et il faut rétablir
il faudrait donc
très attention à ce qui est pas de
coupure dans ces zones là les ARS ont
les agences régionales de santé ont
répertoriés l'ensemble des personnes qui
potentiellement sont concernées sur ces
systèmes de respiration je rappelle
qu'il y a des batteries que les
personnes qui sont les plus à risque qui
ont aussi des batteries de secours et en
plus de ça pour nous ce sera évidemment
des personnes prioritaires enfin je veux
dire on parle de quelque chose d'assez
simple c'est à dire que un gouvernement
et un président de la République ne
laisse pas les gens mourir c'est de ça
dont on est en train de parler
c'est dommage
il est sympa mais il a dit une grosse
regardez-moi
ça a été changé tout le monde dit des
conneries des gens ils viennent ici
parfois je les insultes ils repartent
voilà
oui je pense qu'il a dit une connerie
pauvre mais il mérite pas tout ça voilà
mode merci d'être venu merci je lui ai
donné cinq trucs pour réduire sa
consommation d'électricité un baisser le
chauffage
66 % de la facture énergétique d'un
foyer mais bon c'est une tanné parce que
quand tes enfants tout ça tu as envie de
voilà les petits et puis moi je déteste
dormir avec des gens qui ont les pieds
froid
vous pouvez installer un réducteur de
débit pour limiter l'usage qui vous
permet d'économiser 37 euros par an
puisqu'il faut limiter la consommation
d'eau chaude moi par exemple je prends
que des douches froides
je vous le dis je vous dis que c'est
très beau
alors je vous le dis c'est une astuce
c'est une astuce bien sûr pour le
sportif
et je peux vous dire tu es magnifique
joueur de foot font ça bah moi je voilà
peut-être le faire aussi débrancher son
chargeur éteindre sa box internet la
nuit débrancher son chargeur ne permet
pas d'économiser d'énergie mais il en va
différemment pour la box internet
en fait je vais vous dire il sera aussi
propre il y a 60 je l'ai fait moi je le
lave moi je l'ai fait je l'ai fait hier
encore il avait encore 2018
soyez plus propre
et couvrir les casseroles pendant la
cuisson ça réduit de quatre fois la
dépense
d'ailleurs j'ai fait non mais j'ai fait
un ragoût aux olives et ben j'ai remis
le couvercle et tout s'est bien passé
la cuisine exactement
[Rires]
donc on en prend de la gagne